hear the house judiciary committee i
find it due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor and as a result
the covet 19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronics
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the judiciary committee
the executives this will be an executive
session today
on pending legislation please note that
there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe or listen contemporaneously
through this meeting and listen to kind
of contemporaneously from this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i can
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting is the class
of house rules and rsa 91-a
the right to know law anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call
271-3600 or email
hcs.state.nh.us
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
we do have one staff member who will be
listening in
today attending and that is jennifer for
our committee researcher
eight
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
will be done by roll call vote we'll
begin the meeting by taking roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state whether
there's anyone in the room
with them during this meeting which is
required by the right
to know law i'm ed gordon serving as
chair
i'm at the legislative office building
with others
in the room
and mr clark can you call the roll
[Music]
representative
um good morning i am here in goffstown
my roommate is in the house
representative kurt uh
i'm here i'm in west milan alone
representative
i'm here in rollinsford and i'm alone
representative lorenzo good morning i'm
here in my home office in new market and
i'm alone in the room
representative green
i'm here in my home office in hudson
with my wife
representative oregon i'm here at my
home office in
durham by myself representative kelly
i am here in temple with the dog
daughter's home but not
in the room representative kennedy
i am here in durham roommates are
throughout the house
representative good morning i'm here in
manchester and my husband is home
representative mcbeth
representative macbeth
representative mclean i'm i i'm
president
in the committee room representative
page
good morning excuse me good morning i'm
president and expert
at my home office with children in the
house representative rice
good morning i'm at my home office with
my
husband and kids around
representative masel i'm here at the
lobby
representative simpson good morning i'm
here in exeter and my husband and sons
may pass through at some point but i'm
alone right now
representative smith
um representative smith i'm in durham
alone
and please note that representative
macbeth has joined us so you can call
her
representative macbeth i'm present
in my home office in portsmouth new
hampshire and i'm alone thank you
thank you representative sylvia
i am home alone in belmont
representative toss
uh good morning i am alone in merrimack
representatives good morning
i'm in my home office alone um there are
kids
in the house though representatives
walker is here in llb 208
with a couple of committee members jerry
we
i would note that the
chair received notice that
representative silver would be unable to
attend today
and did receive notice from the
speaker's office yesterday that
representative
would be his substitute today welcome
the uh what we'll do is we'll go through
well plan to go through we have 17 bills
that have been heard these are the
remainder of our house bills
17 bills that have been heard but need
to be
detected and we'll plan to go through
those today
and we'll plan to go through them in uh
in order
by number lowest number first
first bill is house bill 149 this is an
act extending certain civil
immunities to public and private
entities during major
public health emergencies
is there a motion on that
yes i'll move to retain um hb 149.
is that seconded i will stick with that
seconded by representative green
is there any discussion on that
um well what is
i'll just ask what's the rationale for
retaining this particular one so
give me a second i have to pull up the
belt
perhaps representative green could speak
to that
well we just thought there's a lot more
work that need to be done on it i mean
um
you have certain factions who really
hate the bill
the legal community from what we did in
customary really didn't like the bill
but uh they were just we didn't have
we couldn't come to a consensus to it
how does it feel so
that's why i think we should retain
all right thanks yes representative
mclean i think as well there was some
concerns
about the mechanics of the bill you know
the concept is good
but there were concerns about the
mechanics of the bill and we also did
want to put business owners
in in the place of being law enforcement
as were so
there were some things that we wanted to
tease out and felt that
retention might be a good way to go
any other comments or discussion
the motion is to retain the bill
and see no other comments
mr clerk would you call the roll format
on retaining house bill 149
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes
court votes yes representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative marcel
yes representative greene
yes representative kelly
um sorry excuse me i
was on a call um could you
clarify for me which bill we're voting
on right now
the motion is whether or not to retain
house bill
yes representative trottier
yes representative smith
yes representative
yes representative oregon
yes representative diorenzo
yes representative chase
did you hear me yes yes
it's a thumbs up i heard her apparently
okay
thank you you're really quiet
representative kenny
yes representative langley
yes representative macbeth
yes representative page
yes representative simpson
yes mr chairman
yes you know this is 21 to zero
new consent doesn't have to go
oh it doesn't have to
right that's uh uh
people are required to have been
reminded by represent mclean
if you are going to vote you need to
have your camera on at the time
let's build 216 an act relative to
public notice of
access to meetings under the right to
know law
yes it's their emotion that
it's representative alexander yeah
um thank you mr chair i move um hb 216
and expanding to legislate
i'll second that is it
who would like to speak to yes
representative simpson
um i'm actually going to speak against
an expedient to legislative somebody
else wants to speak to it first
feel free
oh sorry i couldn't hear if
representative walper said something
good alexander did you want to speak to
your itl
first um well i think this bill
needs a little bit more work i don't
think that we have necessarily
a need for it at this time i think
municipalities and other groups have
done a great job um
you know adjusting to the realities we
have today
and i think that itlling this bill
is the best way forward thank you
having seconded i just i just want to
add my comments uh the
the one thing about this particular
build
i i think uh i'm not opposed to having
the remote access
but if i read this bill it lets members
decide
whether or not they want to be able to
access meetings
remotely as opposed to letting the
public body make that decision
i think ultimately it should be the body
that decides whether or not its members
should be able to participate
remotely so that's why
i
would you like to speak now
yes thank you um i
uh have heard from a lot of folks in my
district
town officials and others who have
really appreciated using the remote
access to meetings and so i if this
motion were to fail i have an amendment
that
um does a few things that would help it
um
i think be more acceptable to folks i i
don't know if i
am uh permitted to mention what those
things are now
or not but um it does help with
an issue that the um municipal
association had i talked to them
and and added um changed language there
um as well as changed whoever has the
authority to make the meeting remote
change that to the public body as
opposed to the member
um and then also added in in
uh clarification to deal with the chat
function
so i i think that it'd be i don't know
if anyone read my amendment
but um i i think we could fix some
things that might make it amenable
to folks but thank you for letting me
speak
thank you representative sylvia
thank you mr chair um i am opposed to
these remote meetings in in every
possible way
um i it
it it appears to be
more transparent but the fact of the
matter is that
i think it's less transparent it's
it's less organized the people may have
access to
speak to the legislators but frankly a
lot of times we don't know if the
legislators are actually
um listening or hearing um
you know we we tend to do
other things while we are in our homes
we
tend to forget that we are in our homes
and we are not
in a body that deserves a little more
of a formal setting and
so it's not this particular bill i also
have an amendment for
um representative
mcguire's bill the last one that we'll
be hearing to
take out that portion of her bill that
is
to do with uh public uh
remote hearings so i i i just think the
that the process is uh terrible it's
awkward it doesn't get the attention
that uh it really deserves
and to pretend that we are giving folks
more access is a disservice to them
thank you representative
um yes i just want to say this has been
this has been one of the few things
we've had to do since events of almost
exactly a year ago the public actually
likes so
this has proven me very popular um i've
seen that
both uh this body that belongs to the
house and with the senate and also a
municipal government so public um
participation hearings has gone up and
also
in the case of legislature we now
automatically have a recording of
everything that happens in the
mini room which sometimes is good i mean
science is bad but i think that's a huge
step forward before the only record
would really cost
you just can't stay but not that our
clerk doesn't do great work but still
that's a much less complete record than
what we have now so i think this is a i
think this is a large step for
thank you representative smith
uh thank you very much mr chair um
i um i am
opposed to the itl motion
um i want this
to be over i don't want to be on
solitary confinement
any longer i want us to be sitting
amongst each other where we can exchange
views
and influence each other in a positive
way
however forced to have
these zoom calls forced to look at these
little postage stamp
pictures of my colleagues on nonetheless
it has been clear to me that
this process which is painful for us
has opened up the legislative process
in just the way it should as we look
at the number of people who are
attending today there happen to be only
42 people
who are in the attendees list more
than could comfortably fit in our
committee room and we have had
hundreds of people watching us uh
and i believe that we
are elected to represent the people
that's why they call us representatives
and this uh gives us an opportunity
to grow and learn from what had been a
very
for me certainly has been a very painful
time
um as we approach our one year
anniversary of our
20-hour session i
would like to commend representative
simpson who listed
listen very very carefully to every
question that was raised
by the
public particularly the institutions
that we tend to listen to
and her amendment which has been sent to
everybody
addresses every one of those concerns
and i would hope that the committee
would not
support the itl and would instead
consider otpa thank you mr chair
thank you are there other
comments questions i think
so everything that's been said so far
is accurate and for me
i got two perspectives on this one is
the burden on the record-keeping
of these things is enormously more than
it was before
this is my second uh term as courtroom
the judiciary committee
and i have so much work this year that
my wife bought a dog
for a job but it is
and in addition to that
there are a lot of questions about
security
and control of meetings dur using these
technology
the technology that we're using today i
know
board members of boards and towns
who have are absolutely beside
themselves
because they have on pocket reviews and
they aren't allowed to speak
remote from remote during their meetings
because somebody's sitting in the office
just puts them on you there are a lot of
other questions to go with
and so i don't think we're ready to do
this on a broad-based basis
i'd like to say that we are but i don't
think we are
that's why i'm voting on kyo
thank you and representative smith did
you want to speak again
um if that's all right with everyone i
would like to speak again
what representative walper uh notes
he has two points one of which i
completely agree with
and that is um that the system as
it is right now puts um
an undue burden on those individuals who
in the legislature who have volunteered
to be clerk
um and i believe that there are ways
of dealing with that
when we ask the staff and others
to focus on that um i have some ideas
i'm sure representative welker does
the other point that representative
welper made on completely in sympathy
with him
but the story he tells
is the story of someone with behavior
that is
unconscionable by muting
someone within with a an unpopular view
and i believe that by
having that come out in the open
and challenging it and making clear that
in a civil society we expect
disparate views and we respect to expect
to respect those disparate views
i see that as a plus because
that is transparent now
and totally unacceptable
and one would hope that either the
behavior would change or the person who
inappropriately behaved that way
would be embarrassed and or
those people who elected him or her or
appointed him or her
would have learned not to do that again
so
i don't see that as a negative
i don't see the clerk responsibility as
a permanent reason and the pluses
of involving the community in ways that
they had never been involved before
and holding us accountable i believe
strongly outweigh
the negatives and the if the municipal
association
which tends to
be very clear and very strong
in their positions nonetheless could
listen to representative simpson and
accept her
suggestion for correcting their concern
i think we ought to give particular
credence to that
to reward them so that perhaps next time
they'll also consider amendments
thank you representative simpson
thank you um i wanted to clarify one of
the um
issues the municipal association was
concerned
they didn't want there to have to be a
remote meeting
if there was a physical location of the
meeting so that
that would be part of a potential if we
voted on an amendment that'd be part of
the amendment that if there is a
physical location there would be no
requirement
for uh remote accidents
any other maybe communities that wanted
this
any other questions or comments
if not the the pending motion is
inexpedient to
legislate and uh
and we if in fact that fails we'll deal
with
representative simpson's uh potential
amendment at the time
but we're going to vote on it expedient
to legislate and i'll ask the clerk to
follow the rules house bill 216
in expediency i just wait representative
mcqueen
yes representative sylvia yes
clark poties representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes uh representative marcel
yes representative green
yes representative kelly
yes representative
yes representative trot here
yes representative smith
no representative berg
no representative oregon
no representative lorenzo
no representative chase
no representative kenny
no representative langley
no representative macbeth
no representative page
no representative simpson
no mr chairman yes
i supported someone can you firmly
attend the negative
mr chair there will be a minority report
it will be otp a and representative
simpson will be writing it
thank you very much
house bill 232 an act relative to
non-public sessions
under the right to know i have a
promotion
mr chairman i'd like to move otp
it's going to be
yes uh just as a reminder this uh kind
of started with a uh
an issue in laconia that we happen to
find out about
where a property purchase was
negotiated and consummated in a
non-public session and
in fact buried in some bonding issues
that were
given obscure names
so this bill uh allows the
price negotiation to happen in the
non-public session
but it requires that the
the portion of that purchase
is going to happen in a public meeting
so this uh adds transparency to a
an issue that uh certainly needs it
and representative oh yes i was going to
jump in and make the opposite motion
so just so um which i think is a proper
motion i think
um even that one instance i think
doesn't prove that any
law like this is unnecessary i'm not
going to say that
uh the transaction was done right or
wrong but i think that was uh
there were probably probably our
legitimate reasons for um
moving secret anyway eventually
eventually it all
comes out in public anyway so i think we
shouldn't be uh
making this law just to deal with that
one situation in laconia which um
i i i'm not even sure if that
situational company i
never got a good explanation of why what
happened was so terrible so
that's uh i just think this is
unnecessary bill so i would urge you to
turn down the octopass so then an
alternative motion of interconnected
legislate can
be reintroduced so thanks
any other discussion
there's no other discussion
we'll have a vote on the motion this is
on house bill 232
and the motion about the tax
house bill 232 ought to pass
representative mcqueen
yes representative sylvia yes
representative while provo ts
representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative lasalle yes
representative greene yes
representative kelly yes
representative tosh yes
representative troy here yes
representative smith
no representative burke no
representative oregon no
representative diorenzo no
representative chase hello
representative kenny no representative
no representative macbeth
no representative page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman yes what are you
from the attendant negative the
motion about the past is there going to
be a minority report
yes i will i'll plan on a minority for
it and
motion will be as i said itl so
thanks
there will be a minority report from
representative oregon
for expedia the legislature ricksville
is house bill 288 attacked eliminating
the housing appeal board
their motion
288 um i i think
that's mine i'm sorry i i have a motion
for that
um thank you chair i'd like to uh vote
itl uh move itl on that
is that seconded i'm i
second
macbeth did you want to address that at
all yes just just briefly um
chair thank you i just um you know the
board
is in its infancy um the chair announced
that invited us all to attend the first
hearing on april
17th um this uh the continuation of the
board is in the governor's budget and
there was um
really resounding support from the
public um um that day
so um i hope that the itl
um would be considered by my colleagues
and this issue can be considered
maybe a and a year later when we have
some real um
evidence of what the board will do thank
you
any other discussion
seeing them then mr clerk i think you
can call a role this is on the motion
legislative representative mclean yes
representative sylvia no uh the court
quotes now
representative alexander yes
representative bryce no
representative michelle yes
representative green no
representative kelly no
representative toss no
representative trottier
yes
representative smith yes
representative
yes
representative oregon yes
representative dioranzo yes
chase yes representative kenny
yes
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes
that's always 15 in the affirmative six
in the negative
vote being 15 to 6 the motion of
big speed the legislative carries that
would be the recommendation will there
be a minority report from anyone
so i guess that means i'll do it
you want to do a minority report
represent somebody
yes i think uh anytime we have a vote
like that we probably should at least
explain our side okay would that be
ought to pass
yes
hospital 379 an act relative to
electronic
notice
and is there a motion on that
uh mr chairman who will retain house
bill 379.
no second that representative sylvia
so there's a motion made by
representative wilbur and seconded by
representative
silvia to retain house bill 379
there any discussion on that
there's no discussion we'll take a vote
this is on a motion to retay house bill
379.
it's clear if you want to call it uh
[Music]
yes representative sylvia
yes representative yes representative
alexander
yes representative yes
representative yes representative
yes representative kelly
yes representative thomas
yes representative throttle here
yes representative smith yes
representative yes
representative morgan now
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase yes
president kenny yes
representative langley yes
representative yes yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes i've ordered 20 in the
affirmative one in the negatives
i can go ahead to one in favor of
the motion to retain the bill will be
repaid and committed
house bill 402 would act relative to
taxes of property
what did you move representative silva
what's your pass
as seconded by representative mcclay
do you want to address that
representative sylvia certainly uh
just briefly this is my bill that i
sponsored
this sets a very very high hurdle
for property takings in the event of an
emergency
under rsa4 colon 46
this requires uh two-thirds of the house
in
the senate in order to uh take property
i think that uh where we are talking
about
one of the most fundamental rights that
are in our constitution
basically part first article one and two
protect our property rights
and
an emergency that would require
some sort of taking that is a real
emergency
would not even stop to look at what the
statute says so
if there is time for the governor and
the council to
consider an emergency taking then there
is time to involve
also the uh
the senate in the house thank you
representative burch thank you mr chair
um i speak in opposition to this bill
uh i found the argument just presented
curious
in that the sponsor suggests that in a
real emergency
people would just ignore this
legislation anyway
and i scarcely think that's a
a good basis to to pass legislation
under a theory that will be ignored
um i discussed during
our hearing uh about the
uh difficulty in envisioning
how this would work uh in the state in
the time of a natural disaster
and whether um
not the fact of uh emergency
nobody discussed so i want to discuss
for just a moment
the practical aspect of this bill
uh as as churchill said however
beautiful the strategy
you should occasionally look at the
results um
this calls for the meeting during an
emergency
of the house and senate uh
there's two ways that the house and
senate
meet they meet in regular session and
they meet in special session
so let's say this is a call that would
have to be done by
special special session there's two ways
to do
especially call the legislature together
by special session
one requires an act by the governor and
the executive council
then presumably notice goes out to 424
people
and then there's uh a decision to be
made
where they're going to meet i understand
uh
my friend from belmont is not in favor
of remote meetings
so they would have to find a place for
the 424 people to meet
i suspect that would take a week or two
uh to get done
and then notice and the like the other
method of course
is the legislature can call itself into
session
uh that requires according to rsa
16 starting with a petition of not less
than 50 members
that goes out uh and then there's a male
vote by the entire body
once all the mail is collected and
counted if that passes then a special
session can be called
into uh being and
uh that'll probably add an extra three
or four weeks
to the process it's it's called an
emergency because it's an
emergency and the idea
where we can't get our own regular
sessions going
in less than a couple of weeks
the idea that in the middle of an
emergency there's an
act of god that's there's flooding in
concord or
there's a major fire and they need
uh emergency management needs to
move heavy equipment and it might be on
somebody's property
or set up a uh sandbags or
whatever it may be on a temporary basis
that we have to wait two three four
maybe five weeks to get 424 people
together
in some manner probably not remote um
to vote the power to do so is just
is it's a non-starter i mean i
understand the wish to
uh diminish the the governor's power
here
um i i share some of that but
this bill is just a ineffectual way to
do it
and i urge a uh rejection
of the uh the otp motion
representative um thank you
my representative burch said a lot of
what i wanted to say
but first of all i want to say i hope
i hope no one is inferring that what
we've survived for the last year and
what's going to be going
on for a while longer um hopefully we'll
be
back to some sort of new normal pretty
soon but it's going to be a while um
hopefully nobody thinks that that's not
a real emergency i don't think i've ever
lived through any national emergency or
global emergency that was
any realer than this one this is a very
severe crisis i'm not
i'm not aware that uh much taking a
property in this
if you look at the rest of the rsa it's
fairly limited they even
um carved out a special uh exemption in
uh
paragraph roman 1a for for guns so
your guns are protected and then also
any personal property owned by
individuals or families so it's very
restricted anyway
also there's the whole issue how how the
legislature
would would meet um you know i think
certainly
i certainly say back in march or april
2020 it would have been impossible for
the house to meet i don't think you
could have even
even if uh speaker shirtless had figured
out a place
for us to meet in person i don't think
he i'm not sure that he would have been
able to get a quorum so you know the
whole thing uh
you know the whole thing is unworkable
so that's uh
i mean what we could do we could have
some existing
committee like the joint fiscal
committee or we could set up a new one
that would uh
do that that would involve a total
rewrite of the bill and i
don't know whether the third super
majority would be appropriate
then too the whole thing is um i don't
think it's unworkable and we never did
any evidence that any property was uh
taken pursuant to that so like i
haven't seen any examples really
examples of it i mean we did uh
we have certainly entered the rental
agreement for property the governor uh
and half a million dollars running the
phony centers bars and oh
for stomach republican center we spent
some amount of money
uh running facilities from unh more
recently from the llc that don't
see after sports flex in bedford but
that's not a taking of property either
we were just uh
borrowed somebody else's property for
for a limited period of time so i just
this whole bill
this thing is uh this thing is totally
unworkable so i certainly think it ought
to pass it's definitely the wrong
way to go so that's uh that's what i
think
thank you representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman uh first of all
i'd like to say that this is not uh
targeted at
uh our governor either presently or
in the future this is uh targeted
at protecting the rights that
our citizens have and i'll just note
that
this statute was not in existence before
the year
2002 and this uh
wonderful state of ours survived quite
nicely through
many a catastrophe and i think we will
continue with this in place
thank you and representative burch
yes just a quick note that i forgot to
mention
i noticed there's no fiscal note here
i'm curious because i suspect if a
special session
is called
that there's considerable expense
involved i don't know what the cost of
us going over to
uh a sports stadium is
and the transportation cost for all the
reps and
uh the publication that the public can
attend
uh or listen uh but i'm sure it comes
over the
statutory amount and uh i am loaf
to spend money uh the public uh for
something that appears so unnecessary
but uh can there be a uh request for a
physical note
i'm not sure at this point there can be
yeah i guess we have we have to vote on
the pending motion first
before we decide whether or not we
wanted to ask
so this piece of the statue as far as we
know has not been used in the whole time
18 years that it's been in place
uh the calling of a special
session once every 20 years uh that
would be
maybe even once every 100 years that's
a ridiculous argument i'm sorry
i'm not sure representative sylvia we
need to
characterize each other's arguments as
ridiculous but
representative morgan okay i i apologize
if i said anything ridiculous some
but i hypothetically mentioned the
german fiscal committee that committee
actually did continue
meeting um throughout pandemic but
ironically
the uh you know the cares act funding
the extra 1.25 billion of
mana that president trump dropped on us
um that was actually
all spent by the governor set up his own
uh committee dues he actually bypassed
that committee so there's
so that um there's and there's probably
uh so there's no guarantee that a future
governor won't find some loophole to
like uh do what he has to do without the
center for two-thirds of the senate in
the house
and certainly i mean as it was uh
some property was used but uh i know
somebody the grappone center i mentioned
to my contract that was
rented basically at market rates at a
fairly generous rate i'm sure
for unh and the llc that owns new
hampshire sports flex were also
compensated for are using their property
so that would fall under this anyway
so thanks you ready to vote
yes no one else with their hand raised
will take a vote on the motion which is
pending which is ought to pass
on house bill 402 the act rather than
taking some property to declare an
emergency mr clerk
[Music]
house bill 402 ought to pass
representative mclean
yes representative silvia
yes representative wall for both yes
representative alexander yes
representative rice
yes representative masel yes
representative greene yes
representative kelly yes
representative todd yes
representative trottier yes
representative smith
oh you're there sorry i i i didn't
realize i was muted
um no representative birch
no representative oregon
no representative diorenzo
no representative chase
no representative kenny
no representative langley
no representative macbeth
no representative page
no representative simpson
now mr chairman yes
another 11 in the affirmative 10 in the
negative being 11 to 10
is adopted recommendation of occupants
mr i will do a minority report
representative burch will do a and would
that be
in exceeding the legislation uh correct
mr sharon if i may yes
i just want to make an apology to
representative burch for my
characterization of his argument and i'm
sure that would not have happened if i
were
sitting in the legislative office
apology not needed uh but accepted and
uh uh i'll
get that thank you very much
the next bill is house bill 418 an act
relative to supreme court reporting
i think i would make a motion to retain
that uh
you know i'll second that i guess that's
seconded by
representative mclean my
my concern i i
i fully understand the need to
uh modernize the reporting process
but when i heard the testimony from the
court i i
grew concerned with regard to
the timing uh the manner in which it was
going to be done
and whether or not there would be some
type of continuing written record
as a backup and so for that reason
i think i could have some time to flesh
that out if that was possible
without making a decision today
thoughts or comments
seeing them i guess we call the role
this will be on a motion to retain
household 418.
on retaining house bill 418.
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes
work votes yes representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative lasalle yes
representative greene yes
representative kelly yes
yes representative trottier
yes representative smith
yes representative burke
yes representative oregon
yes representative diorenzo
yes representative chase
yes representative kenny
yes representative langley
yes macbeth
yes representative page
yes representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes uh unanimous 21-0
retain that bill for further action
house bill 418 next bill
is house bill 440.
this is jaren uh i have an amendment to
uh hb440 i'd like to move forward to
pass
an amendment so you're moving on to pass
and you're ready to offer
[Music]
yes so this started out as religious
liberties and
uh the amendment zero four
eight six h uh changes this to
civil liberties and the
basics of this is that this will provide
under a state of emergency and only
under a state of emergency
uh the ability to uh put forward
constitutional arguments for the
restriction on civil liberties
and
are we addressing your amendment at this
point in time is that
is that inclusive of your amendment as
it's proposed
that is the amendment yes and what is
the amendment number to you
0.6048
okay representative kenny
ah thank you mr chairman um so i'm
speaking against uh this amendment
i believe the amendment would uh open up
a can of worms that could be a pretty
dangerous
um precedent in the future um it's
reactionary uh to the current emergency
we find ourselves in
i think the way that civil liberties are
defined in the bill will open up
probable possibilities of confusion and
litigation
to have to decide if a governor is
stepping on civil liberties
during a pandemic the governor needs to
make calls
for the bit of granite staters this
amendment speaks frequently to covert 19
so i will state that the mass
mandates and not allowing people to
congregate and other choices were backed
by science
they true enough may be inconvenient but
they were not unconstitutional the
superior court
uh decided the orders were
constitutional um so to conclude
i do think this amendment uh is not
needed and i do not believe
believes civil liberties have been
ignored i think we can all think of
caveats
where we know our rights and civil
liberties are not being stepped on
despite
claims uh such as not being able to yell
bomb on a plane or fire in a movie
theater
i believe wearing a mask during a
pandemic and the other orders that we
saw follow the same type of logic
as these caveats so for these reasons
and to simply put it that the amendment
uh is not needed i urge to vote it down
um
so we can take up the bill thank you
thank you representative alexander um
thank you mr chair
um i while i appreciate my uh
friend from durham's um i think he said
logic and science very frequently i just
think we're heading
too far to the point where science and
logic
is determining um which rights can be
trampled on and which ones cannot and
that really really really concerns me
this bill is much needed and i think
covent 19 was a clear example
of how how far we can stretch these
rights and i just think that
um you know religious liberty it's in
the first amendment for a reason because
it
should be one of your actually it should
be the first uh
right that's protected under the law so
we need to pass this amendment we need
to pass this bill thank you
pretend mclean uh thank you mr cheer i
think
i think this is uh needed legislation
and even though the findings talk a lot
about
the the current crisis in copen 19 i
think this legislation
goes beyond that and my best friend
who is the best man at my wedding and is
you know like a brother to me to this
day
is a japanese canadian i practically
grew up
in his home with his mother telling me
about
how she was interred during the second
world war
and during that time her property was
taken her money was taken
her freedom was taken and her dignity
was taken
and were the people that did this
necessarily evil
i don't think so but there is no dispute
that an evil was done upon her and you
know in spite of that
um she she learned to forgive and she
went to her brain
loving her country um but again
what are the things everybody in this
room is a leader
of a sort and so when a crisis presents
itself to people in leadership
it is natural whether we're the governor
or the people in this room
that we would want to throw ourselves
into the breach
and sometimes trying to do that we can
go too far
not being evil we can nevertheless
commit evil
what stops us from doing that what stops
us from doing that
is the law and this is
an excellent piece of legislation that i
think
clarifies that it goes far beyond the
the current pandemic and i'm going to
support it
other comments
not i think we uh vote on the amendment
first
on the amendment this is on amendment oh
four
eight six h offered by representative
on amending hospital 440
with amendmental for 868 representative
mclean
yes representative sylvia yes
word ots representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative wassel
yes representative greed
representative kelly yes
representative to us yes
representative throw here yes
representative smith this is on the
amendment only is that correct
mr chair that's correct i'll vote yes
representative yes
representative oregon
representative diorenzo no
representative chase yes
representative kenny no
representative mainly now
representative macbeth yes
representative page no
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes i'm the board of 16 in
the affirmative
five in the negative
the vote being 16 to 5 in favor
you have adopted the amendment
house bill 440 as amended is there any
further discussion
uh mr chair of the discussion now is on
otpa
that's it correct i ought to pass as
amen
as amended yes um thank you very much mr
chair i
i voted for the amendment
um because i believe that the amendment
um was far
preferable to the underlying bill
and if in the fullness of time
this committee were to decide to go
ahead
with 440 i wanted it to be
the text of my colleagues representative
sylvia's language however
i believe that um
the the bill as amended
is not um helpful
in any way in any significant way
to protect the civil liberties of
the citizens of this state
um i heard representative mclean's
moving uh testimony
and i too had friends whose families
were
interred and their civil liberties
violated i have friends who today
have their civil liberties and their
civil rights violated
under under existing law
but so the problem is certainly a real
problem but i do not believe
that this amendment
in fact does anything in any broad way
to better protect the civil rights and
civil liberties of the people
of this state and therefore my intention
is to vote
no on the bill as amended
thank you any other discussion
representative mcbeth um
i voted for the amendment as well i'm
wondering if my colleagues would
vote against the ought to pass as
amended and vote to retain it
now that it's been changed a little and
perhaps we could
work on it more um and the fullness of
time
you know come up with something that um
would be supported more broadly
thank you well the motion is pending is
not to pass as amended at this point if
that fails
then we'll consider the retaining
thank you any other discussions
okay uh on the motion about the past is
amended on the house school 440 mr
um octopasses on house bill 440 amended
by 0486h representative
yes representative sylvia
yes representative of ots
representative alexander yes
representative rice yes
representative yes representative green
yes representative kelly
yes representative
yes representative try here
yes representative smith
no representative
no representative oregon
no representative diorenzo
no representative chase
no representative kenny
no representative mainly
now representative macbeth
no representative page
no representative simpson
representative simpson oh sorry no
mr chairman yes
negative 11 to
10 representation about the past that's
amended and will there be a minority
report
uh yes please mr chairman i chill
and would that be expedient to legislate
or yes please
ah yes please mr chairman
who seconded that was it alexander
hospital 478 an act relative to
treatment of pfas contaminants
sir representative mclean i'm following
you representative to retain that bill
is there a second to that
and do you want to address that at all
yeah i mean i think
having litchfield is part of my
constituency
i'm very well aware of the p-pass
situation and i'm very sympathetic to it
i have gone through and amended two fast
bills
um in prior executive sessions but this
one i just think
is too complex for an easy amendment
i'm still not certain does this actually
just belong in the courts
um that we heard a lot of testimony
about the coakley landfill
and as being a kind of the precedent but
i really don't
think we want to get into a place where
the default avenue is always to come to
the legislature
so i think there's a lot of work to be
done before we could go
forward with hb478
and any other discussion
seeing them we have a motion to retain
house bill 478
represent uh representative wilbur mr
clerk would you like to follow the role
i'm retaining house bill 478
representative mclean
yes representative sylvia
yes yes representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes president michelle yes
representative greed yes
representative kelly yes representative
yes representative trottier
yes representative smith
yes representative birch
yes representative oregon
representative oregon
thank you i mean no no no
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase yes
representative kenny yes
representative langley yes
macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes mr chairman
yes
i have devoted 20 in the affirmative one
in the negatives
having voted 20 in the affirmative one
of the negative views devoted to
retaining hospital 478 will retain that
in committee for further
action husco 540 and act relative to
supportive decision making
as an alternative to guardianship
representative chase would you like to
make your own
i would like to make a motion um
although you might have to help me here
i did send everyone a
amendment i i'm not sure if
we should speak on the amendment first
or if we
can just make the motion ought to pass
as
is i gather you're making a motion about
the past and you're going to offer an
amendment for our consideration
very much that's exactly what i'm going
to do thank you
chair thank you and is that seconded by
representative old for a second great
like to address your motion
representative chase i would like to
address that
uh this bill is something that is going
to
make the world of difference in many
people's lives
not just in the disability community but
also as we age and need a little bit
more help and support
with our decision making yet not have
our dignity and our voice taken away
uh there was a lit so do i address the
amendment two at this point or
yes yes
no what there was discussion um
of not caring very much for the language
and the statement of findings
i did understand that very much i could
just enter
interrupt could you just tell us which
you have
kind of multiple amendments which oh i
do oh i'm so sorry this would be the the
final amendment changing the statement
of findings and adding a little bit for
the ipa
ipe it is 0565h
the last amendment that was sent in hey
thank you very much
thank you and i apologize for that
you're right i did have a few
so this um just tried to address the
language issues that some people brought
up about what disabilities were
but i did keep the statement of findings
in
also the amendment does
talk about the recognition of supporters
and what they can do it um
also just changes i'm so sorry
the for um it also changes a little bit
of language
for the iep teams with students and
families
and what their role would be that's line
25 of my amendment
and that
i just think it's a great bill i'm
really excited about it and very proud
to be the uh
sponsor i would hope and urge you to
ought to pass with the amendment another
discussion
seeing none go vote on the amendment
for that yes representative will per
second
and would you like to call the role this
is on the amendment this is an amendment
45658h to house bill
540. thank you on amending house bill
with amendment 0565 h
representative mclean yes representative
sylvia
yes court votes yes
representative alexander yes
representative bryce yes representative
lacelle
yes representative greed
representative kelly yes
representative tosh yes
representative troy here yes
representative smith yes
president yes
representative oregon yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase yes
representative kenny yes
representative mainly yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes mr chairman
yes 21 in the affirmative
zero in the negative uh unanimously
voted in favor of the amendment you have
adopted the
amendment and now we'll discuss this
further discussion
both on the bill as either passed
on house bill 540 as amended by
amendment bill 5658
to pass representative mclean yes
representative sylvia
yes sorry representative uh the court
votes yes
representative alexander yes
representative rice yes
representative lasalle yes
representative greene
yes representative kelly
yes representative tosh
yes representative trottier
yes representative smith yes
representative burch absolutely yes
representative morgan yes
representative deorenzo yes
representative chase yes representative
kenny
yes representative mainly yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson
yes mr chairman yes
that's 21 in the affirmative zero in the
negative
does anybody have an objection if it
goes on the consent count
no
congratulations thank you thank you
everyone for your support
house bill 542 an act relative
to the applicability of a state of
emergency declaration
of worship and
is there a motion on that oh i gotta
find it uh
yeah mr chairman i would like to move on
to pass with amendments
on house bill 542
author amendment 0623h
is there a second to that i'll second
that seconded by representative mclean
and would you like to address your
promotion yes
and uh for
new hampshire made back in december
in terms of religious liberty in the
state of new hampshire and the tests
that the government must
take in order to restrict those rights
and the way they can be
restricted and it further goes
into it replaces the entire bill so it
also includes
the virginian 542 talking about
the treatment of religious organizations
and emergencies
that they can't be treated any worse
than
other similar types of organizations and
i think it's an important thing to
codify all this
because as we looked towards their
decisions with something to change
with no notice of very little notice and
the statute would be a strong
encouragement for them to continue
thinking the long lines they are
protecting our community
other discussion actually we're talking
about the amendment right now
623 h which is
replaces the entire bill which is
any other discussion on it
um yes
senator smith uh yes thank you very much
um
this is one of those bills where we're
treading
on eggshells and i understand that
um it is very important
in honoring our constitution
and our bill of rights to recognize
freedom of religion
and um
i don't think anybody questions that
what i have a problem with um
is that
freedom of religion
stops
when that freedom of religion
interferes with
the rights of others
and
when is that um
is it because some people believe in
um uh
in in in buddha some people
believe um
in the absolute
literal reading of the
new testament but not necessarily the
literal reading of the old testament for
example
no no no no no everybody is entitled
to those thoughts and to those beliefs
and to practice them in any way they
want
what they are not permitted to do
is by practicing their religion in a
particular way
interfere for example with my right
to survival
there have to be some
ways of recognizing both
we have had example after example
after example across the country
of what has happened when in
defiance of
state law and emergency orders
religious bodies have come together
in great concentration
i can't remember the exact number and
and i don't want to misspeak
but there was not too many months ago
a wedding in um
in brooklyn where there were
thousands upon thousands
of observers religious
observers packed together
um in uh
in celebrating that that marriage
the result of that was an enormous
spike in um
in covid and that affected the health of
those people who were there and the
health of those people
who weren't there but had the misfortune
to come into contact with people who
showed great disdain for the rights of
others to protect
themselves the same thing happened in
northern maine the same things happened
in new hampshire
and um in
all the testimony the testimony that
and i think it was for this particular
bill that struck me
uh the most was the testimony about
um people who used the church facilities
um because they were participating in
the 12-step programs and i forget
found that testimony to be very moving
and
realized i know how i feel being in
isolation
and if i needed the support of others
in order to survive
that's pretty important i think
this bill goes too far to say
that um the only thing that matters
is that people should do whatever
could do whatever they want to do in
practicing
their religion even if it's so doing
it damages the life and the health of
other people so
it's not easy it's not an easy decision
but to single out religious gatherings
as um to be protected from what is
viewed as discriminatory treatment
and not to for example
to put that above those 12-step programs
that might not be housed
in um in a religious setting
but in another common setting i think
is to upset the delicate balance that we
have been able to maintain in this
country for about
250 years so i know
that's my position is not a popular
position
but i believe that it is a position
that honors and respects the rights of
everyone to practice his or her religion
as they choose
but does not give them the right
to put others in harm's way
thank you
yeah representative clinton
representative mclean oh yeah thank you
mr chair and
um i think that the
freedom of religion as the prime sponsor
said it
is kind of foundational but i found the
the testimony from the aclu
actually very enlightening that they
didn't
speak at the public hearing but they
sent in written testimony
and in that written testimony they said
that
the the practice to exercise your
religion is not free
of all restrictions and i think that one
of the
strengths of this amended bill is that
it recognizes the ability of the state
to place neutral restrictions
and so in many ways the the amended
language
believe it or not kind of dovetails in
with the um the aclu's written testimony
well i think the reason that this bill
is necessary
is because while it does preserve the
right
of this ability to put neutral
restrictions on religion
the actual testimony that we heard in
committee
was that the practice of religion
was actually inferior and and was
subordinate
it was it was not treated in the same
way as other emergency services for
example
um and i know from my own personal
experience
that it was much easier for me to go
down to home depot
to look at vanities for my
renovation of my home long before i was
able to get into church to receive the
blessed sacrament so
there was there was a definite
difference there
and i think the argument being made
by the folks during the public hearing
was hey
we will comply with these neutral
restrictions but the reality is that we
were held
closed long after many other places were
opened up
and there was not a recognition of our
very important role in the community so
i think all they were asking for is
parity i think that this
bill grants that and i'm going to
support it
representative yes yeah so i i think
that my steve carley has misread the
bill
misread the amendment the amendment
institutes the same standard
the compelling interest standard for the
state
this has been long recognized as the
standard for infringement
of the right to practice your faith
and in addition in emergency
circumstances
and simply such a religious organization
during a state of emergency the state
government shall permit
a religious organization to continue
operating
and to engage in religious services to
the same
or greater extent that other
organizations or businesses
that provide essential services that's
all it says
if they're going to allow other
essential services
that they consider religion to be in a
sense of service and
operate under the same or maybe
booster if they so desire but
on a level playing field
representative simpson
thank you um
so in my private life i'm a christian
pastor and so i just want to say that i
know firsthand how difficult and
heartbreaking it's been for religious
communities
not to be able to gather during covid um
but there were lots of good reasons that
these were treated differently than
shopping for example um
for singing purposes for one um but
there were others as well and i think
the guidelines were
were taxing i won't i won't lie but they
made a way
for creative solutions for how how
religious communities could come
together
and i saw a lot of that from myself and
from my colleagues
where communities could come together
creatively and
safely within the bounds of the public
health protocols
i guess i really feel that the freedom
to exercise religion is enshrined in the
constitution and that that's not going
anywhere
but in the case of these extreme
emergencies like the one we're facing
now
the health of the community behind
beyond the walls of our houses of
worship
is really as important as the spiritual
care that's provided inside
so i don't really believe that we need a
new law that prioritizes religious
freedoms
over public health and safety in a
crisis i'm going to have to vote against
the amendment and the bill
representative
um yes thank you very much mr chair um
the uh bill's amendment still doesn't
have a definition of
of a religion and that's something
that's probably impossible uh possible
to define i remember uh
i remember once i was driving to the
state house i was listening to a uh
spiritual leader it doesn't matter who
was of the myth of the creator god so
excited about how ridiculous it was the
idea of the university of university as
a creator and i'm
not sure where the university has i
pretty much accept the universe as it is
so like whether someone created it or
not is
kind of not a big issue for me
personally but then i
get it it was like a one o'clock access
in the state house and get there the
first thing uh reverend kate
haskins the former uh pastor former uh
house chaplain who i believe she's still
the pastor of the church that's right
across the street from the state house
and
she said mindy does she started saying
many beliefs
one thing we have we all have in common
is the idea that there is a creator i'm
almost like
oh i almost had to suppress my laughter
there just because i've been hearing
someone who describes those religious
leaders saying exactly the opposite that
there is
no creator anyway so i'm not sure how we
can
differentiate religious groups from from
from
from other groups so we certainly are
we're in a situation where it's
extremely dangerous to have mass
gatherings of any type we're
still in the situation where it's
dangerous and i think um
i know it's difficult for church it's
just difficult for probably all sorts of
organizations um but um i think
sometimes
situations prop up like the one we're in
now where
uh we have to have certain uh certain
restrictions
so that's uh that doesn't apply to
organizations that call themselves
religious just suppose
those who don't and also there's people
the 12-step programs um
they're they're spiritual i think they
specifically
claim not to be a religion per se even
though they require certain even though
they
do at least expect people to open the
idea that there is a god and so forth so
that's uh
i just think this is an overly broad
thing it it's open to like incredible
amounts of abuse and
in any case uh i think virtually all the
many religious and spiritual
organizations they found a way to keep
meeting i know like uh the
catholic church i was brought up in they
even had to hold their easter
services and zoom and i have to confess
i'm
describing myself as christian in my
blue book entertainment that's got my
blue book this morning but um
i'm not one of the people who goes to
church very often maybe that's
probably not a good thing but i did go
to a funeral service and we had it uh
we had it outdoors the minister uh
minister had us all stand six feet apart
at the seventh term cemetery we had mass
on and they
zoomed it so they were able to hold a
funeral service in you know full
compliance with uh
all the emergency order requirements and
then some so you know it is uh
it's certainly possible for religious
groups to keep meeting
uh during an emergency as indeed they
have been
during this emergency so i probably said
way too much but anyway i
plan to vote against this amendment and
the bill so thank
you representative smith
oh no i'm sorry i hadn't lowered my hand
from before
anybody else want to weigh in
see no one uh we're going to be voting
on the
amendment this is the amendment 06
h to house bill 542
and that's where if you want to call the
roll
on accepting amendment both 6238 to
house bill 542
representative mclean yes representative
sylvia
yes representative walter both yes
representative alexander yes
representative rice yes representative
yes representative green yes
representative kelly yes
representative toss yes
representative trottier yes
representative smith no
representative no
representative oregon now
representative lorenzo now
representative chase
sorry no representative kenny
no representative langley
no representative no
representative page now
representative simpson now
mr chairman yes 11
10 in years negative we've adopted the
amendment
0623h to house bill 542
and now unless the discussion quote on
the
itself which isn't affecting
amended representative mcqueen
yes representative sylvia yes
represent representative walpole ots
representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative masel yes
representative green yes
representative kelly yes
representative thomas yes
representative troy here yes
representative smith no representative
burke
no representative oregon
no representative diorenzo
no presenter chase no
representative kenny no representative
langley
no representative macbeth
documented adopted the recommendation
about the passive amendment
42 would it be a minority report yes
[Music]
representative simpson uh yeah yes
um mr chair could i ask a question
okay thank you you don't have to answer
it of course
um but i need some clarification i'm
thinking of the two two bills we've
acted on
440 as amendment
amended by our distinguished colleague
representative
sylvia and
5 42.
i'm a little confused about how they are
the same and how they're
different i mean each has had a
significant amendment
and some ways
i thought they were combined am i
can you give me a tutorial having
nothing to do with voting just
explaining the substance of the two
bills to me
well i'm going to rely on each
individual
i can't speak for anyone else who may
have voted so
[Music]
well would representative sylvia or
representative walper helped me out
sure i'll i'll speak to uh 440 it
uh it
is related to general civil liberties
as opposed to the last one which is more
specific to
religious
liberties so i think there's certainly a
difference there
[Music]
so uh
the amendment o623 we just adopted it to
542 did incorporate
a lot of the original house bill
440 which was replaced by representative
silvia's amendment
as this went we went through the witness
on the process the sponsor of hospital
thought that
the language he had written had been
enacted if you will have been decreed
is it been maybe a better word by the
supreme court
in the mac decision in december so
he introduced the amendment that
represented silvia brought to us
to expand the
focus of to expand the whole idea
of protection of civil liberties without
the emphasis on religious freedom
but uh others
thought it was very important
that we not solely rely
on the supreme court decision to
protect our religious freedom
and important that we clarify that
religious freedom should be at least on
the same playing field
as all of our other civil liberties so
we had five 440 as amended that dealt
broadly with civil liberties and
the amendment that was brought into 542
more much more clearly focused on
religious liberty and the importance of
it
getting at least equal treatment with
all others
thank you representative welker that was
very helpful
thank you
i was thinking that perhaps people would
like to take a break
for a few minutes so it's
it's about quarter of 11 so why don't we
plan to come back
that reconvene at 11 o'clock recess
until 11 o'clock
thank you everybody that'd be awesome
thanks
thank you
you
okay
i still can't use the oven but at least
i can cook on top of the stove and that
might clock
okay household 515.
all right so we are now unneeded guys
you know what's another good committee
for discussions
is the science and technology all right
they have some very good deficits oh do
they
yeah you know what
i wish they could have one or two people
on that committee to talk to people
because every one of me gets on
gets up on the floor and i'm gone
start talking about the details of these
things
i think they're getting better at it i
think you guys are broadcasting alive
you know that
yeah you guys are not muted and we do
know that
thank you we're just complimenting our
colleagues
well
see this is one of the problems of doing
this the way we're doing it
when we're not in session we're still on
my
right it's just really not that hard to
figure out
well that happened in the old days
people would say stuff when we're
in the room and other people would hear
it anyway so that's nothing new now just
there's a recording of it unless we mute
the microphone into the room so but
yeah i don't mind taking compliments so
you're welcome it reminds me
having grown up on a farm in illinois
of the old party lines yes
you'd be talking in their beats
oh i had a four-party line in vermont
i didn't really had a belmont but it was
the same thing
they got the phone and people would
already be talking well there wouldn't
be anybody talking and keep staring and
then they just
pick it up and lose travels fast
i remember that as a kid my grandmother
was one of the
original operators in um
well actually new report mass the
switchboard operator so yeah we would
hear a lot
[Laughter]
nice not to have to share that party
line anymore
we're democrats we don't do no stinking
party lines
the mute button guys
hey we will return to our duties
our next bill to africon today is house
bill 550 an act relative to the
non-payment of rent during the state of
imprisonment
uh thank you mr chairman uh i would move
in expedient to legislate on hb 550.
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all i don't know that this bill
is entirely necessary with
all the relief that is already going on
and perhaps by the time that this might
make it through the process it would be
entirely unnecessary
but beyond that um when we talk about
adding costs on to uh
landlords that ends up in one place and
that is
rents and it pushes up
rents for those who are paying and
we already know that we have a
tremendous problem with
uh with folks finding affordable housing
and
this would damage it and make it even
more difficult so
i don't see any reason to proceed with
this bill other than
expedite to legislate
representative page yes thank you mr
chair
um i speak uh in opposition of the itl
would motion for ought to pass the bill
i want
very briefly um this bill is not just
about um
helping the housing and security issue
but it's economic you know
it's economically efficient it provides
a way for courts to quickly dispose
first to continue a case and then
perhaps dispose of it
um quickly if if someone's applying for
rental assistance
i think to the point on relief it's
perhaps
more salient and now
than it was when we first heard
testimony on it because of
additional coveted relief i think
there's somewhere in the north
range of 22 billion and rental
assistance
the latest covert relief package which i
assume the
sign and that would be helping folks
this statute only helps utilization of
that money
so for those reasons i would support
what to pass
thank you any other discussion
yes representative lorenzo thank you mr
claire
and thank you for taking my question um
i think what we need to really focus on
is that this bill
does only one thing it provides a 30-day
extension for non-payment
of rent cases
that have been entered into the court it
does not
interfere with cause evidence
and it only applies
during the pandemic just
a couple of weeks ago the governor's
office um
is in the process of releasing funds to
assist
landlords and tenants with delinquent
rent payments
this is money from the gopher
money that was previously allocated
the money will be administered by the
new hampshire housing finance authority
and it will be distributed by the cap
agencies
now what's great about this these gofar
funds is that um
the payments will go directly to the
landlords so
i see this as a win-win for landlords
and for tenants thank you
representative alexander um thank you mr
chair
um the money that's coming from
um the gopher funding is already
something that's being
um given to our landlord and tenants and
has really
not a lot a whole lot to do with this
particular bill um
i think the housing there is a
significant housing crisis
but again i think the issue is with
supply
more regulation we put on landlords and
tenants
the more it's going to exacerbate this
crisis this bill needs to be
itl thank you
any other discussion this is on house
bill 550s
see none we do have a motion pending
that's for inexpedient to legislate
so you know further discussions would
you like to call the role
to legislate house bill 550
representative mclean
yes representative silvia
yes representative walter votes yes
representative alexander yes
representative grace yes
representative yes representative green
yes representative kelly
yes representative tosh
yes representative frater
yes representative smith
no no
representative oregon no
representative
no representative kenny
no representative langley
no representative macbeth
no representative page
now representative simpson
no mr chairman yes i belong
in the affirmative
mr chair if i could i think
there will be a minority report on this
i'm sorry just acting too quickly
and representative page
yes it will thank you
[Applause]
an act relative to potential jurors
excuse and jury duty due to a lack of
residency in the county
of jury service
we have a motion hand up
yes i move out to pass on hp
561. it's there
a second seconded by
representative alexander
and would you like to speak to that
representative
yes thank you mr chairman um this is a
rather simple
um proposal
to help
i think it'll help our supervisors of
checklists
to purge some old data
simply uh cleaning up uh
the the voter rolls if people move and
they don't
uh re-register or
you know there have been occasions where
people were
registered in two places and uh
inadvertently forgot about it and
uh ended up voting in two places so we
could help
avoid those sorts of situations i think
that'd be a benefit for everybody
thank you mr chairman um so i'm speaking
against the recommendation
this bill on the surface i was actually
looking forward to the hearing because i
was curious
what problem it would be solving why
this list
was necessary who was excused from jury
service
but the first words out of the sponsor's
mouth was this bill is about voter
integrity
uh he referred to it as a small tool
that could be used for
uh tracking potential fraud um
and and i'll
i i just think that it's it's in the
wrong committee and and i believe there
was a back and forth conversation
um between two members where it was
questioned why if this is the intent it
was
would not go to election um and the
response
um was well how would you how would you
tell it to go to
election law and i think that's a very
fair point and i i think if it's not
in the proper uh committee because the
intent is that not clear
it's not ready to pass um that aside
based off the merits and the senate said
intent i do not believe
um the prime sponsor introduced to us an
actual problem that we have
in new hampshire so for that reason i am
speaking against this recommendation
um and would offer itl thank you
thank you representative um thank you
very much mr joe i can uh beat my muted
for once
thank you very much mr chair i agree you
had the sponsor he described it as voter
integrity but i would use a different
noun after
voter hyphen so first of all uh
jury duty jury lists are compiled not
just from the
voter rolls from from other places in
fact one of the reasons why people are
reluctant to vote
um is because they're afraid to be
called for jury duties and so these
things uh shouldn't be coupled together
there are
there are other sources that the court
used just to compile a list of uh
citizens who live in the county also um
this bill doesn't even do what it
intends to do because it simply says
they're going to publish a list on the
secretary of state's website
which even those recently upgraded is
not the most user-friendly website but
it doesn't give
anybody any power to do anything uh with
that list
um so like it doesn't authorize the
supervisor supervises the checklist
there's nothing that says they have to
look at the list i'm not even sure if
they'd be authorized to hurt somebody
from it just based on that list so
that's uh
that's another problem so aside from the
fact that i disagree with
what it does in principle we also need
to maintain the confidentiality of the
juror
of the jurors and also it just doesn't
do what it sets out to do
so there's three good reasons right
there to ipl it thanks
any other discussion
if not we have a motion about to pass on
house bill 561.
let's go 561 entrepreneurs
representative mclean yes representative
sylvia
yes defended alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative lacelle
yes representative greed yes
representative yes
representative todd yes representative
trottier
yes representative smith
um no representative burch
no representative oregon
no representative diorenzo
no representative chase
no representative kenny
no representative langley
no
no representative page
no representative simpson now
mr chairman yes
you've adopted the recommendation about
to pass
representative kenny are you going to do
a minority report
uh yes please an expedient legislate
thank you thank you
and house bill 566 and act relative
records in non-public section under the
right to know
like to move by pl so
representative alexander's hand up first
i think okay fair enough
thank you um thank you mr chair
um i would like to move out to pass as
amended and offer
amendment um zero four two five h
it was that zero four two five h yes
this is here
and is there a second second to that
i'll second that
would you like to address your motion
representative alexander
um sure so um there were some concerns i
had with this bill
last year when was presented by the
sponsor however i believe the sponsors
addressed those concerns with the bill
filed this year
this bill would require regular review
of sealed minutes of non-public sessions
by making them public after one year and
if the circumstances around these
minutes
have changed then the local board can
after review release those minutes
um if the board chooses to keep these
minutes sealed they're allowed to keep
them sealed with a two-thirds vote
vote um the amendment that i have moved
addresses concerns by the municipal
association
and also has the support of right to
know new hampshire um i think this is a
great bill that will allow for more
transparency in our government and i
encourage everyone to vote for
the amendment in the bill thanks or any
other discussion
yes representative oregon um yes well i
i
i would i would have offered a uh motion
for itl and if
if this fails i will offer one so i
think this is a
first of all it cut it makes a special
uh
provision for um the language about
subparagraph 2d that's the real estate
transaction
so it covers the same ground as 232. so
i'm up opposed to it
special treatment of that one for the
same reason uh i'll be
i've closed it hb 232 also think uh just
a basic idea of
fortune to public bodies to vote on the
uh
vote on the minutes of all the sealed
minutes going back to however long back
to like
any of time i think that's uh that's an
unnecessary burden they would
theoretically they could theoretically
be spending their whole time just
constantly
voting at every meeting on uh
on the old unsealed record so that just
seems uh
seems like a waste of time although
they'll probably work around it by
writing the rules so they'll just have a
consent calendar of the
minutes or something so i think uh i
don't think
i just don't think there's any need for
it and uh and there already
is disclosure of like which minutes have
been sealed so like
somebody's really really concerned they
can go back to it and
ask for the unsealed i'm not sure about
other things
where the minutes are sealed they're
like not of much lasting interest anyway
i believe
so i would urge you to
vote against the amendment but against
the uh underlying bill and then um
move on to an itl so thanks
i'm opposed another discussion
in the motion independent uh actually
what's pending right now is an amendment
offered by representative alexander to
house bill 566.
there's no further discussion on that
i'll pass the clerk
on amendment 04258 on accepting
amendment
04258 for house bill 566
representative mctwain yes
representative sylvia yes
representative walker's lts
representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representatives myself
yes representative yes
representative kelly yes
representative thomas yes
representative trott here yes
representative smith no
representative no
representative oregon no
representative diorenzo no
representative chase no
representative no
representative langley no
representing his page now representative
simpson
uh simpson no
mr chairman
we've yes the amendment commitment
0-4-2-5-h to house bill 566
unless there's further discussion we'll
vote on the
recommendation of octopus
hospital 566 amended by amendment 04258
representative mccoy ought to pass as
amended representative mclean
yes representative sylvia yes
court forties representative alexander
yes
representative rice yes representative
yes representative green yes
representative kelly yes representative
yes representative charlie here
yes representative smith
no representative no
representative morgan no
representative diorenzo
representative chase no
representative kenny now
representative mainly now
representative macbeth no
representative page representative
simpson
now mr chairman yes i have an auditing
affirmative time in the negative
so we've adopted the recommendation
about to pass as amended
uh and president morgan are you doing a
minority report
um um yes does your preference be that i
attack the
i it'll be brief in either case but
should i be arguing against the otpa or
the original bill although i suppose the
same arguments apply to both
i think you'd be arguing itl okay thank
you
578 and act relative to standards for
mental health courts
and i think i would make a motion of
itl on that particular
record second second within a mclean
and the reason the reason i have what i
frankly my understanding was that this
came out of a study committee
and the study committee basically said
there ought to be statements for mental
health courts
and that their the mental health courts
are being conducted by the courts right
now and the way they've
got that consistent manner
that they're applying different
standards in different courts
and so what the bill does
directs the chief justice of the supreme
court
to do a report with regard to adopting
standards
and i guess i have two issues with that
the first issue is i
i don't think it's up to the legislature
to tell another branch of government
in this particular case the chief
justice of the supreme court
that they need to do a report and i
guess the second
part that i have of that since
we've already adopted provisions in our
constitution which it
allows them to adopt rules that have
the full force and effect of law
there's no reason in the world that the
court can't do that
on its own accord so
i just i think the bill is is
unnecessary i and i and
and frankly in terms of ordering the
chief justice to do something
i don't think it's appropriate so that's
why i would make the recommendation in
expedient
thank you mr chair and uh
with with hesitancy i want to speak to
the other side of
what you just addressed uh i was part of
the
the commission that looked into this
issue
trying to establish uh federal health
courts statewide which we have not been
able to do so far
unlike drug courts where there are
national standards
there are not national standards for
mental health courts
so not having national standards
and having different issues that
mental health courts would have in more
rural areas in terms of
for instance accessibility to judges
and transportation all those other kind
of things
are very different in uh rural courts
than in more urban courts um
it was the sense of the
committee or the commission of the a ton
of various stakeholders
to say that the supreme court
the top of the food game as far as
mental health courts go
uh should be the one to devise a system
that will work
in new hampshire um the uh
this proposal has not been objected to
by the supreme court the supreme court
is
very able to send a
spokesperson over to our committee and
say that they felt this would be
inappropriate they had did not do so
in fact as i recall judge nadeau of the
superior court
uh came in and testified in favor of
this proposal
so in the absence of objection from the
supreme court
on uh the technicality that our chair
has brought forward
um we need to move it forward the most
efficient and best way to move this
forward
uh according to the stakeholders a very
broad base
of stakeholders uh was this
proposal most came in here
with support one after the next after
the next after the next
and i would hope that this committee
would support moving the
mental health court process forward
representative thank you mr chair
um and with all due respect of
the chairs experience and the judiciary
which i um
greatly um defer to but
i really i feel like this bill um
instead of
um being a breach of the three
branches of government and the
allocation of power is really um
just authorizing an internal audit of
this program
um which would help them coordinate
their services
and i i think that now we know covet has
been a
pan you know a health crisis but from
that has from
a mental health crisis and i feel that
it's a
timely issue because
this audit will give us you know current
information on the demand and need
of resources for this court um so i
asked um
i asked my colleagues and the chair to
consider that and
if this amendment could be withdrawn and
we could consider um
to pass thank you
any other discussion yes
so we just recently had instituted drug
courts across
the state and it seems to me that the
mental health courts are following the
path
to drug courts followed and that was
first you can try it and
you find out what works
and how it can be implemented and then
you come in and say
we want to do this across the state and
this party was very acceptable
but i don't see why the mental health
support is different in the sense that
we never told the judiciary branch
how to implement drug forwards we never
told them
what standards to establish or how they
would operate and i don't think we
should be doing it now
just one follow-up on the comments that
there is a difference between the drug
courts in the mental health courts and
that
the drug courts are in the superior
court
mental health courts are in the circuit
and judge the doe testified but judgment
is in the superior form
not in the circuit court where where the
mental health courts
are and we really didn't hear from
the circuit court and i do have concerns
and i think it gets to your
inquiry uh representing macbeth which i
think is appropriate and
the question is are there resources in
the
if you you can adopt standards but are
there resources
in the circuit court to actually hold
mental health because i think it's been
the desire of the circuit court for a
very long time
to expand the mental health court
program
but they just don't have the resources
in order to be able to
do
representative burch yes that's true
there is a resource problem which is why
this was going to come back sooner or
later
to the legislature anyway no matter what
to answer representative walper's
question there already are national
standards
in the mental health world we didn't
have to come up
with best practices there are no
candidates adopted nationwide in terms
of mental health courts
excuse me i met earlier say drug courts
drug courts have
national standards mental health courts
do not they do not run on the same model
the method of delivering sir
in fact looked into whether it should be
one group
doing both or whether it should be done
separately
the service providing the service theory
is different in both cases
so again um if
it was felt that the supreme court was
in the best place to come up with a
comprehensive
set of standards which would work for
the
courts that they supervise and and
staff and they can look at the at the
places that already have it
in our state and use that information
discussion comments
hustle 578 inexpedience legislative
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes
representative wolf of ots
representative alexander
yes representative price
yes representative lacelle yes
representative green yes
representative kelly yes
representative yes
representative trottier yes
representative smith no
representative burke
representative oregon no
representative diorenzo no
representative chase no
representative kenny no
representative mainly no
representative macbeth no
representative page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman yes well there is
[Music]
i i can i don't know if we had someone
else lined up or not
happy to do that i'm happy to do it but
you um
have spoken so eloquently and we're on
the committee so
are on the commission study committee
rather so
representative burch i'll defer to you
if you all right
i understand the problem representative
birch that might arise and we'll deal
with that
okay fair enough
mr chairman yes when you get to the next
bill
would you let me make the motion
i would uh i'd be pleased to do that
are you ready for that on 597. this is
an
act relative to the expectation of
would you like to make a motion mr chair
i would like to move retain
and the reason i ask to make the motion
doesn't necessarily have to do with the
substance
since i actually in fact think this is a
good bill
and i think the amendment makes it
even better it answers all the
opposition
but i have a feeling mr
chair in the back of my mind
that if i in fact move retain
this might be another opportunity to
show
how well the judiciary committee works
together
and on that basis i would like to move
retain
representative mclean would you like the
second half i'll second that
so i moved by uh representative smith
and seconded by
representative mclean to retain this
bill is there any discussion on that
support would you like to take the role
on retaining house bill 597
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes
represent uh representative
representative alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative michelle
yes representative green yes
representative kelly yes
representative todd yes
representative trottier yes
representative smith yes
representative yes
representative oregon
representatives yes
yes i would representative dioranzo
yes representative chase
yes representative kenny
yes representative langley
yes representative macbeth
yes representative page
yes representative simpson
yes this is chairman yes
that's the united stand
mr chair thank you very much for giving
me the privilege of making that motion
it makes me feel so much better you
thank you for making the motion
it's been a so far it's
been a pleasure to work together
on what we've done so far this year
and that brings us to the last goal for
the day house bill 630
an act relative to remote board meetings
of the right nova
and authorizing procedures
yes mr chairman um while i originally
was
thinking that this bill should be
entirely killed i would like to move
uh otp and offer an amendment
is that second i'll second it
that's representative
you can speak to that representative if
you'd like to
thank you so i would like to offer an
amendment
and this is a
fresh amendment um
you would have gotten from uh our
uh assistant uh jennifer four this
morning at uh i think it was just around
nine o'clock we got this through
but the amendment is uh 0 7
5 3 h
and this amendment
strikes section 1 from the bill
which is about the uh 91a and remote
meetings
and it leaves intact uh sections two
three and four
renumbers those two uh one two three
and that leaves uh the signature
um allowance for that uh particular part
of the bill
so um this is the only way that i could
uh
find a save half a loaf um and
this is what i offer
representative macbeth do you want to
speak to it too
yes i will um thank you mr chair and
thank you
um representative sylvia um so i really
um
didn't realize this bill would be
controversial at all it's a got
bipartisan it's a republican prime
sponsor and bipartisan and
senate support um it's was um
offered by many every sponsor
is a member of last session's
administrative rules committee and it
seemed
to me just like it was a bill to help
our government um
you know process uh rules quicker and
faster
and representative uh sylvia's amendment
does
take out a very important part of the
bill to me but in the effort to work
bipartisanly and to um save half a loaf
i'm willing to support um this amendment
and um uh
have the bill go through as otpa i
realize we're just voting on the
amendment now but
um there's where i am thank you very
much
represent horrigan um yes i think the
section one is uh the most important
half of the load so and uh
and i know i know where it changes the
way
public bodies have to run their meetings
but i think this is something that
i think is i think this is
something that's a very good idea it's
also been extremely popular public
participation
in uh public body meetings of all sorts
including legislative committees has
gone up
and that's uh generally a good thing
i'll be
oh it's totally a good thing i'm not
going to qualify it and um so
in any case it's also it's just uh
enabling legislation so it just
says that they may have the
remote telephone and video options which
uh
some have been doing for years already
so there wasn't anything prohibiting
them from doing it before
so that's uh um i mean it does serve
with the
it just sort of put the onus on you know
chair the members of the public body
decide not to have it they will probably
the public will now like
demand well why aren't you doing it so
like
so when they that's gonna be that's
gonna be a problem for public bodies
that don't want to do it but
i think uh they shouldn't do it and for
the second
part that i actually had a little more
doubts about that but i think the second
part is good but uh i'll
definitely vote against the amendment
and uh second part i'm a few minutes
away but i still haven't decided because
i don't
know that's uh that's a big deal anyway
and we already have visions for
electronic signatures
that's already been done too so um
anyway so the amendment
i think it's a bad amendment um bill
it's a bad amendment of a good bill so
i i urge you vote no in the amen thanks
what else want to address it
representative simpson thank you
i just want to say about the amendment
that um as we know from previous bills i
am
for for the remote language that's in
there but also
the bill is more than that and anything
we can do to facilitate rulemaking which
it seems like the
um those who requested this bill put in
see this as an important um important
bill to pass
i'm in favor of the amendment
thank you any other discussion
we can vote on the amendment this is
amendment 0.753h
to house bill 630 mr
an accepting amendment post 7538 south
bill 630
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
representative alexander yes
representative rice
yes representatives
um yes representative reed yes
representative kelly yes
yes representative charlier
yes representative smith
yes representative burke
yes representative oregon
no
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase
yes from her yes
representative kennedy yes
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes
either that's 20 you've adopted the
amendment to house bill 630
is there any further discussion at this
point
it's not mr clerk you can call the roll
on the recommendation of octopass
hospital six thirty is needed by seven
five three h
pass as amended representative mcclain
okay representative yes
representative silvia yes
representative of ots representative
alexander
yes representative rice yes
representative silver is not here
representative lasell
yes
greed yes representative kelly
yes representative josh
yes representative trottier
yes representative smith
yes representative burke
yes representative oregon
no representative diorenzo
yes representative chase
yes representative kenny
yes representative mainly
yes representative macbeth
yes representative page yes
representative simpson yes
mr german yes
20 defermented one in the negative
you've adopted the recommendation about
to pass
it that concludes
the bills that we have pending today i
just want to go through just to make
sure you understand
will that go on consent before oh yeah
yeah but um
uh representative horrigan do you want
to do a minority report
thanks for asking no but i i'm i'm happy
to let it go through on consent since i
would have uh
would have voted for this if it had just
come through originally as a standalone
bill and the other issue had not been
attached to it so
without objection it's fine put on
consent
i have no objection to that then the
objection i'll indicate should be on the
consent calendar
representative chase yeah yes
i i just have something i wanted to um
say before we finish out
but i wanted to get my hand up so go
ahead and do the announcements and then
i'd like to just
make a comment on bill 478
okay i'd like what i'd like to do is
just go through the bills to make sure
we know who's writing the
reports so
on house bill 149 i have
uh representative rice and actually
that's a retained bill we don't need to
worry about that house bill 216.
that was representative alexander
writing the majority report
and representative simpson writing the
minority report
house bill 232 representative silva
and representative morgan writing a
minority report
on house bill 288 representative macbeth
uh writing the majority report
and representative sylvia writing the
minority
house bill 379
okay house bill 402
representative majority report and
representative burch writing the
minority report
house bill 418 is retained
house bill 440 representative silvia
writing the majority report
and representative kenny writing the
minority report
house bill 478 representative mclean
that's the retaining bill sorry house
bill 540 representative
chase writing the majority report and
that bill would be on the consent count
plus bill 542 representative wolfer
writing the majority report
representative simpson writing the
minority report
house bill 550 representative silvia
writing the majority report
representative page writing the minority
report
representative house bill 561
representative sylvia writing the
majority report
house bill 566 representative alexander
writing the majority report
representative corrigan writing the
minority report
house bill 578 i'll write the withdrawal
representative birch writing the
minority report
597 is retained in house bill 630
representative silvia is writing the
majority report
and that would be placed on the consent
challenge
if you can get your reports to me by the
end of tomorrow i would greatly
appreciate that and i'll get them
out
my comment that before i call upon
representing chase it's just to say uh
we went through a lot of business today
we did it very efficiently and
uh credit to the committee and
we didn't agree on everything today but
i have to say that the committee did web
did his business very respectfully today
that's greatly appreciated everybody's
cooperation in doing that
and representative chase did you want to
have something to say
thank you mr chair i did because i
raised my hand but i
was hesitant and um you didn't see it
and that's fine
i i'm glad we're retaining this bill but
i just wanted to say coming from an
another small town although merrimack's
not just
real small but we have a village water
district ourselves
and we have have run into quite a few of
the same
instances as um the mvd
but not necessarily pfest but just
having trouble trying to get the state
to to um either settle things or just
sort of step in and
help us so i completely understand what
it is they're doing the
frustration the um
things that were made like the
agreements that were made
kind of in the closed sessions without
letting the people
of the village district vote on it which
has happened to us as well
i know that's part of the procedure it's
different than a town
uh but i i really do hope that we can
find a solution
and help them with this problem because
i think they're
they've got the underhanded deal here
and really need to try to help with the
water
situation and the the damage that's
being done by saint cobain
and other places as well i don't want to
put all the blame there
but i just needed to say that because i
felt bad that i didn't
stick up for for the um
what this what's the town's trying to do
their village district
that's it thank you i feel better
yes so so mr chairman do you have any uh
idea what this schedule for this
committee will be between now and the
time of the f session
or you know the the only thing that i
know is at some point in time we'll be
getting senate bills we don't have any
senate bills at this point in time
obviously i'm not going to waste people
time
one or two bills you know i'll wait
until we get critical mass
so that we can be efficient in the way
we use our time
but as soon as we do get critical mass
on senate bills i certainly will
call the meeting the committee back
order again
uh mr chairman would it be worth our
while to do a little work on
one or more of the retained bills that
we have yeah
uh if you if the committee would like to
work retain bills uh
might as i indicated last time what i'd
like to do on the retain bills
is if in fact there are bills in which
there are people who would like to form
a committee i would be more than happy
to
appoint that and have them work on those
retained bills
if they're if there are bills that we've
retained
that people don't spend their time
working on individually as small
committees i'm more than happy to
work on it as a committee as a whole and
deal with them
when we have to fall
mr chair do you need the speaker's
agreement if you are to act uh to start
acting on retain bills now
i'm not acting start working on retain
bills now
sometimes the speakers over the years
have
had strong feelings about that and i'm
not
don't i'm not privileged to speaker
um packard's views
uh well joe i i'll join you with that
so i don't know my my guess is that he
has no objection to people working on
the bills the question is whether he's
going to pay mileage for people to do
that but
that's been the problem in the past but
um or
to be in the building during the middle
of the summer so
uh but i will find that out
thank you mr chair morgan
yeah what is the time frame for
for acting on the conductivity what
happens
if we come to consensus uh before the
usual
october or november uh timeline where
retaining bills
under so-called normal circumstances are
are dealt with
like is there any chance of voting any
of these uh
up or down uh before january 2022 or
we're pretty much uh they're on hold
till then which uh
i will be here soon enough so not maybe
not a terrible thing
i'm not anticipating acting on any of
the bills prior
to the end of the year thank you
representative yeah just to let members
of the committee know
that uh i'm working on the conservation
you're frozen
he's back oh uh and
the anyone who wants to contact me every
reached out to stakeholders and but
anybody on the committee wants to reach
out to me and either work on it or
provide suggestions you know how to
reach me what was this
the conservationism yeah it's 82.93 one
of the two
representative chase no i just was
my on saying that i would um i would
help you or like
to be involved in that all right great
is there anything else that
i just want to uh as has been pointed
out already
once today there's a lot of work that's
been placed on the clerk and i just want
to
appreciate the fact that uh kurt has
done
woman's work in terms of all the work
that he
that he's
i've had great support in particular
with regard to the
hearings we've had with regard to
representative mclean as well
and i certainly want to compliment
representative smith
who has been wonderfully
cooperative in terms of getting things
done
it's a pleasure to work with you
representative gordon even
when we don't agree
okay is there anything else people have
if not we'll adjourn to the call of the
chair
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you goodbye colleagues